[Music]
oh no
it is officially the 30th anniversary of
home alone it's one of my favorite
movies of all time
it's actually one of my first movies
that i watched on vhs coming to the
united states in 1995.
boy did i just age myself i'm watching
some of the most painful clips
from the two movies i know some other
channels have done this years and years
ago let's give a huge thank you to them
for coming up with the idea
injury reaction time i can't seem to
find my toothbrush so i'll pick one up
when i go out today
other than that i'm in good shape
if you have ever shaved and then put
aftershave on it does burn a bit because
there are micro tears of the skin
and when the alcohol seeps in there it
actually causes burning and stinging i
actually had a horrendous experience
like this when i went swimming in the
dead sea
if you don't know what the dead sea is
all you need is a picture to see the
blocks of salt floating in it and
i actually shaved my face before going
and actually i think my body because i
wanted to get an even tan
when i went into the dead sea and i had
those little micro tears from shaving
oh my god my body caught on fire so i
know what he feels like
this is such a typical pediatric injury
ankle sprains could be quite common here
knee sprains
and also because the shells actually
fractured and broke like that
those wooden sharp edges can give you a
serious serious laceration that's nice
presents for you
be a good little fella now and open the
door
i'm assuming based on his reaction it
hit him
in the testicular area it had to hurt
there's a lot of nerve endings there and
it's also quite dangerous because
there's a lot of blood flow there so if
you rupture some of those blood vessels
you actually get expansion and swelling
it could actually lead to a condition
known as testicular torsion
where the spermatic cord that leads to
the testicle actually
kind of spins on itself and cuts off the
circulation to the testicle
which leads to a lot more pain and even
the testicle dying if it's not treated
surgically in time
[Music]
oh
[Music]
the reason he's probably doing the
is he had the wind knocked out of him
imagine landing so hard
that it actually expels all the air out
and you're not able to normally take a
a breath in because remember in order to
take a deep breath in your body has to
create negative pressure in order to
suck the air in and if you can't expand
your ribs because they just got hit and
they're
uh dazed you can't create the negative
pressure needed to take a deep breath
oh no
oh that fell right on his
face you could easily fracture your
orbit which is your uh the bone
surrounding your eye like imagine if it
hit him dead on into the eye you could
lose the eye completely but
what i don't understand here is how it
hit him so perfectly on the forehead but
then didn't break his nose
immediately after getting a burn you
don't want to necessarily go and put
into something icy because that can
actually exacerbate the burn it makes it
feel worse so you want to
run uh your burn under room temperature
if anything the danger
of receiving a burn especially on the
hand
is when burns heal they often form scar
tissue that form contractures which
actually
lead the hand to be in a flexed position
and when it's in a flexed position like
this it makes it very difficult for it
to be
usable so a lot of occupational therapy
physical therapy needs to be done in
order to return the hand
to normal also important to remember
that there's multiple types of burns
from heat meaning thermal burns electric
burns
chemical burns there's even ice burns
like if you hold dry ice onto your hand
that's like minus 100 degrees fahrenheit
or whatever it is
you can burn your hand with the ice
that's why when we recommend icing your
knee or your shoulder or something
we always say put it over a piece of
fabric so it's not directly on your skin
because then you can actually cause
yourself frostbite frostbite is
essentially a burn
oh no
not only did he have a puncture wound
from a nail in his foot he
fell from like the eighth step if you
ever are to get like a nail in your foot
while it's important to get it out after
a period of time you don't want to rush
to do it yourself in case that
it's hitting an artery and actually
putting pressure on that artery and
preventing you from bleeding out because
it's very
possible okay you pull it out and now
you just have a ton of blood coming out
and if you're not in a medical setting
to address that that is a problem and
make sure your tetanus is up to date
oh that's a full thickness third degree
bird the way that we do it in the
medical setting to decide how severe
someone's burns are outside of the first
second and third degree we also give a
percentage
of the total body surface area that has
been burned and we use the rule of nines
and we decide what percentage is burned
how we should adjust and we think about
fluid replacement
if a large percentage of the body's
surface area has been burned
that uh cripples a person's ability to
keep their fluids and they actually
become dehydrated
and need fluids with electrolytes
repleted quickly
otherwise they can go into hypovolemic
shock their kidneys can shut down and
they could die as a result of this
dehydration
heads up
[Music]
a lot of people don't realize when you
fall on your back you really don't
support your head well so your head
ends up hitting afterwards your brain
actually suffers
trauma onto the side that you got hit as
well as the other side
of the brain it's actually called a
counter coup type of injury where
the brain slides to the back hits the
back of the skull but then because you
landed and you
shake it actually hits the front of the
skull as well so you have injury on both
sides of the brain
marv what are you doing come on
oh my god not only can you fracture
ribs in the sternum if you hit like the
point of maximum impulse from the heart
and you hit it right at the wrong time
in the middle of its beat
you can actually stop the heart from
beating this is like a known phenomenon
in little league baseball if
you hit a grounder and it hits the child
in the chest right at that moment
it could actually stop the heart and
that's why there's mandated
defibrillators that need to be
present at little league games because
of this
well hello
he did it did what
oh she has a strong punch for a
one-punch knockout
easy easy to break a facial bone here
easy easy to get a concussion here i
feel like this is what logan paul vs
floyd mayweather's gonna look like you
get electrocuted through an alternating
current it's actually really difficult
to let go of whatever object is causing
electrocution and you can start
developing muscle spasms
cramps shaking arrhythmias of your heart
seizures
all these things start going because
your body has a natural
electrical gradient the way that your
heart beats the way that your brain
fires once that is interrupted by this
extraneous
bit of electricity it's incredibly
painful and damaging to your body
no
[Music]
no we actually have criteria that we
follow of when we should be cat scanning
folks head
when they come in from a trauma and part
of that criteria
is knowing the mechanism of injury
falling 40 feet
from the air onto a metal car and having
it shatter like this
is the definition of needing a cat scan
brick from the fourth story whatever
that is
to the head you're not getting up from
that if it hits on an angle especially
that's death first of all good aim but
that's death
[Music]
oh my god the second concussion is
always worse than the first when you get
your first concussion your brain gets
shaken up there's inflammatory cells
your brain is very susceptible to
getting permanently injured so
right here the fact that he got one
concussion and then got hit with another
brick he's getting six months of
headaches
six months of light sensitivity if not
dying immediately like i don't know
what's happening
oh my god
oh my god
there's so much wrong with that he got
shot in the groin with a nail
that's gonna need a urologist like
that's gonna need urgent surgery you
need to see if any structures were
damaged you need to put it back together
in the face there's nerves in the face
you can disrupt nerves you can lose
sensation in the face
[Music]
okay like when you hear about people who
survive skydiving accidents or falls
it's almost usually because something
broke their fall or they fell onto a
hill where it was like an
angle and their momentum carried them
and they didn't just come to a complete
stop
my man here came to a complete stop why
is that dangerous because your body
comes to a complete stop but the force
doesn't
so the force goes right through
everything all of the organs smash
against themselves
the bones break because they're hitting
oh
harry i've reached the top
okay two bricks in the face from the
three bricks from the roof maybe he got
lucky
two-story fall onto the face death like
you're not surviving this like there's
no human that's surviving this he's
bleeding out internally
just everything in his body should be
broken at this point
[Applause]
yeah no no i know this is a movie but
i'm trying to critique the medical
accuracy nonetheless
speaking of medical accuracy here's me
pranking some of my close doctor friends
or if you need a good laugh here's me
reviewing some of the snl
commercials that they had medical
commercials you know medical
advertisements because we do that here
in the states
as always stay happy and healthy